make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with
dead planet right with deceased dead
planet part four and in the last video
that we did we basically talked about
how you had
constantine showing up to mr miracle
right scot-free basically saying hey
look we are looking for
metron right like we need to get into
new genesis we need to get a hold of
metron because we need to find out from
the mobius chair where the cure is right
the problem with this is because
one does not simply just walk into new
genesis right like you don't let me just
go there
and then demand the chair of metron
right it's just it just simply doesn't
work that way and so you get this this
kind of you know boom tube explosion
right into the
safe zone basically like the safe area
that was created by poison ivy that
everybody kind of resides in at the
moment and you've got like you know
mr miracle who shows up here and
initially it was like damien wayne
thought he was dead right it's kind of
like dude i thought this guy was dead
like dude this guy's alive man this is
kind of crazy not only that of course
scott freeman makes a comment about how
batman shrunk
right damien's wayne's smaller than
bruce wayne but the the whole idea here
is they kind of give us you know we kind
of get this little bit of a run over
right this little bit of an explanation
in the sense that
cyborg might have the cure inside of him
but they simply can't access it and that
metron's mobius chair contains all the
knowledge of the new gods right and so
if there's an answer to be found
it's in there but the whole thing here
is is it's kind of one of these funny
little scenarios dinah lance remember
when when jonathan passed out he didn't
know where black canary was
they call her green canary basically but
i didn't know where dinah was the fact
that diana tried to bring the body of uh
of oliver queen
into the sanctuary and poison ivy said
no donna got pissed and then she kind of
went off on her own and so you have
jonathan who gets out there with
basically mary marvel because we know
they're gonna be a couple and dine is
out there of course she's glad to see
that jonathan's alive
but they kind of have this bit of a
conversation here and they're talking
about the idea of oliver right oliver is
basically alive he's just kind of kept
inside this uh green lantern stasis
stasis bubble right he just he's there
but he's kind of not there if that makes
any sense but the idea of mary marvel is
okay
surely we could try to find some way to
get him inside right i mean we could try
to get past poison iv and we can have dr
fate put a kind of protection spell on
him but at the end of the day it's still
a huge risk this is why sentimentality
is usually often the end of things it's
cool to care about those that you care
about that's nice but we're talking
about the end of the world here and
there is no room for somebody who could
conceivably kill everybody in this place
by
all they have to do is basically bite
them right so it's kind of like that
quote from from the dark knight rises in
this place
innocence cannot be a flat allowed to
flourish it has to be stamped out right
that's basically what this is so yeah it
sucks it's kind of cruel but
that's just kind of way it is from here
you kind of have this romantic moment to
share between cassie sandsmark
and damian wayne and i just want to
throw it out there this makes perfect
sense and i actually dig this whole
thing more than i dug the one with raven
and damien during the uh the dc universe
the final movie they made apoc it was a
dark side war or apocalypse war or
whatever it was they were calling it i
kind of dig this more than i dig raven
here's my question
do you like damian wayne with cassie
sandsmark or do you like him with raven
i'm kind of curious because i figure i
feel like teen titans fans will be like
raven
and then like anybody else will be like
cassie sandsmark
i feel like that's what it's gonna what
it's gonna kind of come down to but of
course they basically end up arriving
here on
new genesis right the home of the new
gods and when they get there you kind of
have this little bit of a fight that
goes on between orion and scot-free
right because remember they are
basically brothers right for those of
you guys who don't really know the
relationship between these two
the idea is that um at some point in the
past
it was it became obvious at least it was
kind of done by metron but it became
obvious
that apocalypse which was ruled by
darkseid and new genesis which was ruled
by highfather that they were going to go
to war and they were going to lead to
the destruction of presumably everything
in the universe given the power that
they had and so because it would lead to
the end of all creation
metron ended up proposing a truce and
this truth came in the form of them
swapping their sons
and so orion is the biological son of uh
of darkseid and he resides on new
genesis and scot-free is the biological
son
of high father and he resides on
apocalypse and that's basically how they
kind of maintain this truth that neither
one wanted to see their son die was
really kind of it but then basically you
know with this
kind of fight breaking out you have you
know jonathan who sort of jumps in he
ends up taking out orion but then of
course they're met by the arrival of
high father and you would expect high
father to be hostile towards them right
to be like what are you doing in my
house right
get off my lawn you know go all clint
eastwood on him not at all he's actually
just kind of like like
he's he's there and he's like i mean
it's kind of good to see you again right
it sucks that you lost big barta but you
know like it's it's good to see you
again
not only that you kind of get this
explanation from scott free and saying
hey look we need to know if you can call
out to metron right i mean you're a new
god and you're you're basically high
father right so you're the ruler of new
genesis metron will answer you he's not
your errand boy but he's not gonna show
up here and say what can i do for you hi
father you know anything to please the
king today that's not what's gonna
happen he's like but he'll show up here
if you call him right if you summon him
he'll appear you know
so he's like we need you to bring him
here and he's like well the problem here
is that metron
will not give the chair willingly and
metron's not someone who he's not ruled
over by me right he's only ruled over by
his quest for knowledge so even if i do
calm there's no guarantee he'll answer i
guess we can give it a shot because me
calling him will
probably achieve a greater percentage of
success than you right because why would
metron listen to scot-free
so uh at the end of the day you know you
kind of have this thing where
high father ends up calling scott free
off to the side and what you end up
learning here
is that scot-free and big barta actually
had a son together which is kind of
crazy right
i'm i don't know if in the main dc
continuity if that's actually happened
i want to say they have not but i'm
probably wrong i'm not 100
i'm not 100 sure there but regardless
scott freeze got a kid and the idea was
at the beginning of all this you know
really even before
this whole outbreak seemed to happen
that big barta and scot-free kind of
left him here
with hi father now we're not really
given like a full-on explanation as to
why because you kind of have you know
scott freer sort of cuts off high father
at the the last minute but
the whole idea behind this we're kind of
given just this sort of explanation in
the sense that
scot-free cannot give his son what he
deserves which is why he's not here that
kind of seems to be
an extension of their original logic
which was that they couldn't really
protect him in the way that he needed to
be protected or they couldn't give him
what he needed this is interesting
an interesting situation because the
response of high father is that with
darkseid gone
uh it's entirely possible that his son
could rule over you know the son of scot
free could rule over
one day right he could he could rule the
universe one day and at the end of the
day if scott free knows that does he
want
his son to basically be raised you know
in the the mindset of himself right to
be raised by by scott free himself or
under the influence of like orion or
high father or light ray like how does
he want that to work
and so when the question's asked by high
father like what's the point of all this
right like what's the goal of what it is
that you're looking to do here and
getting metron here
and and trying to cure all this the
response to god scot-free is i'm trying
to bring his mother back but i'm trying
to bring back big barta
we can save everybody and if we can save
everybody then we can grab my son and we
can raise him in a productive way
and so the the response of high father
is okay but something that you have to
keep in mind here is
big varda may not be able to come back
whether you succeed with her or not is
irrelevant you have to come back for
jacob right you have to come back for
your son
you have to grab your son you have to
take him out into the universe you gotta
raise him right to become the best
version right like he's a piece of your
wife and if your wife can't come back
he's all that's left of your wife do you
really want to abandon that
right or do you want to raise him and
help him become a productive member of
the universe right to become the best
version of himself and so from there you
pick up with you know superman and you
pick up with with these guys you know
cassie sands mark and all them kind of
hanging out by an asteroid and mr
miracle basically just standing there
waiting for for metron to show up and
the metronome of course as soon as he
arrives
mr miracle is like hey man so like you
know when when metron's like hey dude so
like high father summoned me said that
you you have something you know to see
that you know
that allows me to see the future and
like scott free's like yeah man it's
this
right here you know and he's like you
know i can i could see your future in
this metron you know he's like i can
definitely see your future and then like
they attack him right like
[Laughter]
which of them being honest with you guys
is a pretty shoddy plan right like if
we're if we're being honest with
ourselves that's a pretty shoddy plan
like
that was never going to succeed right
we're going to just run up on metron you
know this super powerful guy
who's bound by knowledge and we're just
going to attack him and then we're just
going to
like take his chair right like that's
not going to happen and in fact metron
gets the upper hand on them
pretty fast and that's when when
jonathan catches up to him now
this is jonathan kind of filling the
role of his dad right because this is
something that only superman really
could have done but he basically shows
up to metron and says hey look i never
really wanted to fight right like we
need your help here right we need your
chair for a simple moment and then we'll
give it back right earth is being
consumed by the anti-life equation and
the response of
metron is i don't care and that's when
mary marvel really proves her worth here
that mary marvel uses the wisdom of
solomon to say yeah but like you're a
curator of knowledge right you are being
who cares about knowledge more than
anything in the in
anything else in the universe you're one
of the smartest men in the entirety of
the universe right like
imagine what the universe would be like
if all the knowledge on earth
was lost right like what happens to all
that knowledge and that's like that's
the thing that kind of gets him in he's
like okay cool like i'm on board all
right cool you should have over with
that instead right so he says like let
let me have that ball that scott free
has and i will look at everything this
has to offer right i'll look at
everything here and just kind of get a
glimpse and
then uh you guys can sit on a mobius
chair and do your thing right so like
we'll trade and it's like cool beans
right so uh you end up having
cyborg who gets on the chair and cyborg
it's kind of a funny thing right we
almost kind of get this tease
about like the the war the war against
existence that's to come
seemingly what it looks like what tom
taylor is kind of throwing at us here is
we're going to see this scenario where
like this huge
this massive conflict on earth is going
to spread out into the universe right
it's going to become massive which makes
sense that's typical tom taylor to take
a story that takes place on earth and
expanded out into the greater universe
so presumably all the lantern cores and
all that kind of stuff i'm not really
sure but that kind of seems
that seems to be what's going to happen
there but then of course he ultimately
ends up finding the cure and says that
he
needs to recode his blood that the life
equation is essentially in there for
metron
metron takes this orb looks at it once
and it's like i gotta go and like bails
right it's like he's
literally just books and they're like
dude he looked at this thing for like
one second and then ran away and they're
like yeah man i think it's time to leave
well the reason why he ran away is
covered when we pick up with the black
racer
right basically the the the kind of
nature like the aspect of death that
exists right for new gods and for
speedsters and so on and so you end up
basically picking up with like what was
what's left of apocalypse right like
this little core piece of apocalypse and
literally like the racer is witnessing
all of this go down he's watching all
this happening that inside this small
little tiny facet of apocalypse that
dark side reemerges right dark side is
not dead and so then like in the midst
of all that
you suddenly have like high father and
you've got you've got jacob and all them
you've got like all these these folks on
new genesis who are there and like this
this
looks like a meteor comes crashing down
onto new genesis right like comes
crashing down onto this place and
there's
there's basically nowhere they can go
right because by that point in time it's
essentially
too late unliving dark side was already
there that's what he's called
unliving darkside which is an amazing
name right like it's a ridiculously good
name but anyway guys
uh we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like i will catch
you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you